[Musique]
bonsoir
anormaux nours ça ne va pas non pas trop
et qu'est ce que tu as je suis trop gros
tout le monde m'appelle gros nounours oh
là là que c'est russe ne voyant tu es
bien portants tu a bonne mine c'est tout
au long patron je sais bien que je suis
trop d
il faut que je maîtrise que je devienne
mince élégant que je me surveille
au régime nounours
on ne te désole pas on t'aime comme tu
es et nicolas et pimprenelle t'attendent
c'est vrai juin europe hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop
au nom gros gros ses fidèles je vais
devenir un pôle où
nicolas raison à partir d'aujourd'hui
plus de gâteaux lu de sucre plus de miel
pour nous et du sport
de la gymnastique tôt
l'haltérophilie
peu
tout les haltères de papa très bonne
idée courage l'ours ou
deux le show deviendrait brasse france
comme l'assurait
il connaît comme la paire elle vient du
poids mais thad il court il court le
plus belle le ferais tu vois que j'ai lu
il a passé par ici il
a passé par ici
cool sur les voies gérées il a passé par
ici il
repassera dans parlons
[Musique]
et voici un verre d'eau fraîche pour
l'adresse papilles merci propre vol
oh
ça va mieux tu vas manger quelque chose
mon giro n'ont rien à manger
hélas
cheveux sont bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
il est courageux
howie
committee frères tort bien par e mail
[Musique]
alors comment te sens-tu nounours en
pleine forme pas trop
mes courbatures
aux plateformes et bien en route en
route une
bonne nuit les enfants fait pour eux
[Musique]
oh